l a france a manqué à ses devoirs envers
les harkis leurs femmes et leurs enfants
a déclaré lundi emmanuel macron le chef
de l'état a annoncé un projet de voie de
reconnaissance et de réparation ce 25
septembre marque la journée nationale
d'hommage aux harkis ils ont été des
milliers à être venus en france après la
guerre d'algérie elles ont été entassées
dans des camps de transit et de
reclassements notamment à bias dans le
lot-et-garonne andré azoulay est un
enfant de 5 ans désigné officiellement
sous le nom de centre d'accueil des
rapatriés d'algérie le camp de la honte
pour andré une prison à ciel ouvert aux
conditions de vie déplorables
il est revenu sur les lieux avec notre
correspondant hervé grandchamp regardez
donc le camp il faisait 400 mètres
environ de large sur 8 900 mètres de
long
nous étions 1200 personnes dans ce camp
environ 1 800 familles voilà moi
j'habitais précisément ici et à savoir
qu'il y avait des baraquements
tout le long des baraquements entre
chaque baraquements il y avait des
toilettes on avait des toilettes à
l'extérieur il fallait vider des sceaux
en prenez des sceaux la nuit avec nous
et au petit matin on les vider dans les
toilettes ce bâtiment là c'était le mess
des officiers
ici au camp c'est le dernier bâtiment
qui reste au compte de bias à savoir que
tous les autres bâtiments ont été rasés
pour effacer la mémoire de bias
dont il y avait un gardien
qui a qui contrôlait les allées et
venues et qui rend référer au chef du
camp monsieur boucher voilà ça c'est le
périmètre de chez moi de la maison où on
vivait à à 6 et mon père avec 7 avec mes
parents à tous hervé deux pièces
pas de toilettes
lavabo à l'intérieur pour un lave
vaisselle
et une cabane ici à l'extérieur pour le
charbon quand je regarde cette photo je
retrouve l'intérieur de ma maison une
véritable de chaises et tout le reste
vide
voilà
monsieur macron a demandé pardon à la
communauté harkie et c'est très
courageux de sa part parce que c est
seul président qui l'a fait jusqu'à
présent néanmoins cette reconnaissance
et cette préparation cette fameuse loi
il y à aigle il ya quelque chose d'assez
ambigu là dedans parce que il dit aussi
nous n'allons pas juger le passé si on
ne peut pas juger ce qui s'est passé
réellement et dire les raisons pour
lesquelles cette loi de reconnaissance
et de réparation doit exister cette fois
n'aura aucun sens qu'on privilégie plus
l'ancien ennemi que ceux qui l'ont servi
parce que monsieur macron il a été
invité à bias
il avait promis de venir à bias et bien
c'est pas la jerry seah moins loin que
l'algérie ben non on va personnes venir